hi drew i heard that you liked my diy tv  frame and so here are my step-by-step  instructions on how to do it  you buy baseboard molding and then cut  it at 45 degrees to the size of your tv  and spray paint the pieces  you get wood appliques and spray paint  those as well  put your frame together and add corner  braces  add hanging hardware and i decided to  add this step of more definition by  adding crown molding trim i cut those at  45 degrees added them onto the inside of  my frame  and then just spray painted that as well  i added an extra step of putting rub and  buff for the antique gold finish look  here's where i mount the frame put the  tv on the tv mount and the final step is  adding some gold washi tape around the  edge of the frame this way you get rid  of the black frame around your tv and  your remote sensor will still work and  it blends seamlessly with your new gold  frame